.
>>> WITH SCHOOL BOARDS AND
CONSERVATIVE GROUPS PUSHING FOR
BOOK BANS IN RECORD NUMBERS, WE
CAN'T OVERLOOK THE ROLE OF STATE
LEADERS WHO ARE SHAPING WHAT
CHILDREN LEARN IN SCHOOL.
JUST THIS WEEK, FLORIDA GOVERNOR
RON DeSANTIS ADDRESSED HIS,
QUOTE, STOP WOKE ACT, WHICH
RESTRICTS RACE-BASED
CONVERSATIONS IN BUSINESSES AND
IN SCHOOL AND OFFERED THIS UP.
>> IT WAS THE AMERICAN
REVOLUTION THAT CAUSED PEOPLE TO
QUESTION SLAVERY.
NO ONE HAD QUESTIONED IT BEFORE
WE DECIDED, AS AMERICANS, THAT
WE ARE ENDOWED BY OUR CREATOR
WITH UNALIENABLE RIGHTS, AND WE
ARE ALL CREATED EQUAL.
YOU CAN'T HISTORY THAT'S BEING
USED TO PURSUE AN IDEOLOGICAL
AGENDA.
>> BACK WITH ME, VAN JONES,
DAVID SWERD LICK, AND SCOTT
JENNINGS.
VAN --
>> SORRY, SORRY.
>> I HAD THE SAME REACTION.
SLAVERY DIDN'T END TECHNICALLY
UNTIL 1865.
1776 -- THAT'S ALMOST --
>> FIRST OF ALL, YOU REVEAL A
LOT WHEN YOU'RE SPEAKING ABOUT
STUFF YOU DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT.
HE SAYS, NOBODY QUESTIONED
SLAVERY UNTIL -- YOU KNOW WHO
QUESTIONED IT?
THE ENSLAVED PEOPLE.
>> THE SLAVES.
>> THE ENSLAVED PEOPLE
QUESTIONED IT THE WHOLE TIME.
AND THAT'S THE THING.
IT'S LIKE YOU HAVE A WORLD VIEW
THAT'S SO CENTRIST AND SO
PRIVILEGED, PARTICULAR
IDEOLOGICAL AGENDA THAT YOU SAY
THINGS THAT ARE PATENTLY
RIDICULOUS.
THERE ARE KIDS IN THAT STATE OF
ALL COLORS, ALL FAITHS, ALL
HUGHES, AND HE HAS TO DO A
BETTER JOB REPRESENTING ALL OF
THEM.
AND ALSO THE REALITY IS KIDS
AREN'T STUPID.
I'VE GOT A COUPLE OF THEM.
TRY TO GET THEM TO BELIEVE
SOMETHING.
THEY PUSH BACK.
THEY FIGHT BACK.
THEY THINK.
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN POINTS OF
VIEW.
THE IDEA THAT IF YOU PRESENT AN
IDEA TO A KID THE KID IS JUST
GOING TO SWALLOW IT WHOLE, IT'S
NOT TRUE.
IT'S NOT TRUE ABOUT KIDS.
IT'S NOT TRUE ABOUT HUMAN
BEINGS.
WHAT'S DANGEROUS IS WHEN YOU
DON'T LET YOUNG PEOPLE DISCUSS
THE WORLD AROUND THEM.
HE'S CONCERNED THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE HERE WHO ARE
ANTI-AMERICAN, ANTICAPITALIST,
ANTIWHITE, ANTI -- THOSE PEOPLE
ARE A PROBLEM.
BUT THE WAY YOU DEAL WITH THOSE
THINGS IS THAT YOU TALK ABOUT
IT.
WHEN YOU DON'T TALK ABOUT IT,
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO ADDRESS IT.
I WAS VERY OFFENDED.
AND I'M VERY -- I TRY TO PUT UP
WITH A BUNCH OF STUFF.
BUT FOR HIM TO SAY THAT NOBODY
CRITICIZED SLAVERY UNTIL THE
SLAVE HOLDING AMERICAN FATHERS,
FOUNDING FATHERS, DECIDED TO
RAISE IT -- AND NOT ALL OF THEM
DID -- DISQUALIFIES 200 PEOPLE
OF PEOPLE ENSLAVED.
>> THE STATE HAS BANNED, I THINK
IT'S THE SECOND HIGHEST NUMBER
OF BANNED BOOKS IN THE STATE.
IS THIS A WINNING TACTIC?
I MEAN, IF YOU WILL?
THIS IS JUST STRICTLY
POLITICALLY.
>> I THINK WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
SOME REPUBLICAN OFFICE HOLDERS
RESPOND TO IS THE CONCERN
THEY'RE HEARING FROM SOME
PARENTS ABOUT SOME CERTAIN KINDS
OF TOPICS, MATERIALS, BOOKS,
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CALL IT
BEING INTRODUCED TO THEIR
CHILDREN.
AND THEY DON'T AGREE WITH IT.
AT ITS CORE, YOU HAVE PARENTS
WHO DON'T WANT VERY, VERY YOUNG
CHILDREN BEING TALKED TO ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, SEXUALIZED MATERIAL BY
PEOPLE OTHER THAN THEM.
AND SO I THINK THAT'S AT THE
ROOT OF THE TACTIC.
WHETHER IT GOES TOO FAR IN
CERTAIN INSTANCES AND WHETHER
PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO DISCERN
BETWEEN, YOU KNOW, WHO CAN
HANDLE WHAT, I THINK THAT'S THE
DEBATE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE.
>> YOU SEE A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE SEXUALIZED MATERIAL, THE
GENDER CONVERSATION, MULTIPLE
GENDERS, ET CETERA, VERSUS
AMERICAN HISTORY, SLAVERY, THAT
KIND OF THING.
I JUST WONDER HOW YOU SEE IT.
>> OH, YEAH.
AND I THINK IN THIS DEBATE AND
IN THIS CONVERSATION, ALL THESE
THINGS GET LUMPED TOGETHER.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> SO, THERE'S NO DOUBT
REPUBLICAN OFFICIALS, OFFICE
HOLDERS, ARE HEARING DAILY FROM
PARENTS WHO HAVE GROWN QUITE
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS.
SO, AS A TACTICAL MATTER,
THEY'RE RESPONDING TO THAT.
AND, YOU KNOW, I'VE GOT A FEW OF
THEM MYSELF.
AND I'VE TALKED TO A LOT OF
PARENTS AT SCHOOLS.
AND ONE OF THE CORE THINGS I
HEAR FROM PARENTS IS, YOU KNOW,
WHY ARE THE SCHOOLS SPENDING SO
MUCH TIME ON TOPICS THAT AREN'T
SORT OF THE CORE LEARNING
CURRICULUM THAT I GREW UP WITH.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE RESPONDING
TO.
AND LET ME TELL YOU, IT IS A
RISING SENTIMENT IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
I EXPECT IT WILL BE A MAJOR
TOPIC OVER THE NEXT TWO TO FOUR
YEARS.
>> IT'S DEFINITELY A RISING
SENTIMENT.
BUT IT ALSO HAS BEEN PUSHED.
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT THIS HAS
BEEN SOMETHING -- I THINK WE
HEARD IT FROM A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT LEADERS IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY WHO PURPOSELY
TARGETED SCHOOL BOARDS IN
PARTICULAR AND SAID THIS IS THE
NEXT BASTION OF WHERE A FIGHT
NEEDS TO GO.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT USING
SCHOOLS AS A POLITICAL
BATTLEGROUND?
>> YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT, SARA.
AT SOME POINT REPUBLICANS
DECIDED MAKING THE WHOLE COUNTRY
THE TOWN IN THE MOVIE "FOOT
LOOSE" AND SO FAR IT HAS WORKED.
I THINK UNTIL IT DOESN'T WORK
AND ESPECIALLY FOR SOMEONE LIKE
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS WHO WANTS TO
BE PRESIDENT, THEY'RE GOING TO
KEEP DOING IT.
I AGREE WITH SCOTT THAT PARENTS
DO SOMETIMES SAY, LOOK, AT THE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL LEVEL, WE
SHOULD FOCUS ON READING,
WRITING, ARITHMETIC.
MAYBE IT'S NOT THE TIME TO FOCUS
ON SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUES IF
THAT'S WHAT THEY THINK IS GOING
ON.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S ALWAYS
REALLY WHAT THEY THINK IS WHAT'S
GOING ON.
ON THE OTHER HAND, ONCE YOU GET
TO MIDDLE SCHOOL, HIGH SCHOOL,
TO VAN'S POINT, WE HAD SLAVERY
AND SEGREGATION IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE HAD JAPANESE INTERNMENT AND
THE ZOOT SUIT RIOTS.
WE FOUGHT A CIVIL WAR OVER
SLAVERY.
TO SHIELD STUDENTS AT A CERTAIN
AGE FROM THOSE FACTS, FROM THOSE
REALITIES WHO ARE BENEFITTED WHO
ARE SUFFERED, WHAT HAPPENED, HOW
WE GOT WHERE WE ARE NOW, IS NOT
EDUCATING KIDS.
AND I THINK THAT MESSAGE HAS
GOTTEN LOST IN THIS WHOLE
DEBATE.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THIS
VIDEO THAT HAS GONE VIRAL.
IT'S A TIKTOK VIDEO OF A TEACHER
TELLING A STUDENT TO STAND UP
FOR THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
LET'S WATCH IT.
>> THEN GO BACK TO -- WHERE ARE
YOU?
MEXICO?
GUATEMALA?
AND YOU WON'T STAND UP FOR THE
FLAG.
>> SO, THE TEACHER SAYS, WHERE
ARE YOU FROM?
I WHY WON'T YOU STAND UP.
HE STARTS ASKING HIM WHERE HE'S
FROM.
YOU CAN HEAR A STUDENT GIGGLING
IN THE BACKGROUND.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT SENT OUT A
STATEMENT SAYING THE TEACHER NO
LONGER HAS CONTACT WITH
STUDENTS, STRONGLY CONDEMNING
THE BEHAVIOR.
THE CONCERN WAS THAT HE WAS
TRYING TO SAY THE STUDENT WAS
FROM SOMEWHERE ELSE OR WASN'T
AMERICAN.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT?
>> I THINK THAT IF TEACHERS WANT
TO ADDRESS SOMETHING WITH A
STUDENT REGARDING ANY KIND OF
BEHAVIOR THAT THEY DON'T LIKE OR
SOME DISAGREEMENT THEY'RE HAVING
IN THE CLASSROOM, IT'S BEST TO
DO THAT IN PRIVATE, AND IT'S
BEST TO DO THAT IN A RESPECTFUL
MANNER.
>> NOT TO SHAME THEM IN FRONT OF
OTHER STUDENTS.
>> I MEAN, LOOK, I UNDERSTAND
WHY HE WAS RELIEVED BECAUSE ANY
TIME YOU START TO TALK TO PEOPLE
LIKE THAT, A, THAT'S BAD.
BUT, B, WHEN YOU START TO DO IT
IN FRONT OF OTHERS MAKES IT EVEN
WORSE.
SO, LOOK, I WAS RAISED TO STAND
FOR THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE,
AND I CERTAINLY WOULD.
BUT, AGAIN, I JUST THINK THE
INTERACTIONS BETWEEN TEACHERS
AND STUDENTS IN FRONT OF OTHER
PEOPLE -- AND KIDS ARE
VULNERABLE.
THEY'RE NERVOUS.
AND THEY'RE EASILY -- YOU KNOW,
IT'S EMBARRASSING TO BE CALLED
OUT BY AN ADULT LIKE THAT IN A
SETTING LIKE THAT.
I THINK HANDLING THING